نتابع بالزلزال اذا مشاهدينا ازمه سكن
حاده تواجهها تركيا بفعل الزلزال والسكان
المشردون في المناطق المنكوبه يتجاوزون
المليونين بحسب خبراء تركيا تتعامل مع
واحده من اسوا حالات التشرد في العالم في
اعقاب الزلزال حيث تسعى الحكومه لتوفير
الماوى لمئات الالاف من النازحين لاوائهم
لجات الحكومه فعليا الى خليط من الحلول
المؤقته بما في ذلك اقامه مخيمات ومنازل
من الحاويات في ضواحي المدن المدمره ايضا
اخلت السلطات الطلاب من مساكنهم الجامعيه
في جميع انحاء البلاد لافساح المجال
للناجحين الانتقادات لم تاتي من الطلاب
وعائلاتهم بل جاءت من المتضررين والمعارضه
السياسيه بسبب ما يصفونه باستجابه الحكومه
غير المنظمه وغير الكافيه وسط الغضب
الشعبي المتزايد اعل الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان يوم الثلاثاء عن مجموعه من
الاجراءات منها مباني عاليه الجوده لتلبيه
احتياجات الاسكان في منطقه الزلزال
باكملها في عام واحد اردوغان قدر عدد
المنازل المنهاره او المتضرره بشده ب 2011
منزل بينما يتوقع خبراء ان العدد لا يقل
عن 400 الف منزل ما يجعل اكثر من مليوني
شخص دون ماوى اضاف الرئيس التركي انه تم
نصب اكثر من 175 الف خيمه في منطقه
الزلزال لايواء النازحين على ان الحكومه
تبدا ببناء 30 الف منزل جديد في اوائل شهر
مارس على الارض قال الاتحاد التركي
للمؤسسات والشركات ان الاضرار الاقتصاديه
التي سببها الزلزال قد تصل الى 84 مليار
دولار على الاقل على ان يخصص الجزء الاكبر
من المبلغ الاعاده بناء المنازل والبنيه
التحتيه واستري جورنال الامريكيه قالت في
تقرير لها ان الوضع الماساوي في المناطق
المنكوبه حول ايصال المساعدات الى توتر
بين الحكومه ونشاطاء الاحزاب السياسيه بعض
الجماعات المجتمع المدني اتهمت وكاله
الكوارث الحكوميه افاد بعرقله عمل
المنظمات غير الحكوميه لتحقيق مكاسب
سياسيه قبل الانتخابات القادمه احدى
المجموعات المعارضه تمكنت من بناء مخيم
صغير على مشارف اديمان وقالت ان العديد من
شاحناتهم التي كانت تحمل خياما للنازحين
صادرتها اداره الكوارث والطوارئ فيما
امتنعت الاداره عن الرد على تقرير الصحيفه
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]